[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal sur tv 60,18 voici
les titres de ce mardi 3 décembre des
réfugiés tibétains accueillies en
hébergement d'urgence à villepreux ils
sont arrivés cet après midi au complexe
alain mimoun en provenance d'achères où
un camp de fortune a été démantelé les
600 migrants qui vivaient sur place ont
été mises à l'abri dans dix sites pour
la plupart dans les yvelines
il est situé sur la rn 10 au croisement
de maurepas la verrière et coignières le
carrefour de la malmener de balle budden
va être réaménagée à l'horizon 2026 le
projet prévoit notamment est de créer un
pont au dessus de la route nationale une
concertation publique a lieu jusqu'au 20
décembre
et puis c'est également un grand dossier
du moment à voisins le bretonneux 500
logements vont voir le jour dans le
futur quartier de la remise une réunion
publique se tenait hier soir le
programme du téléthon à suivre également
dans ce journal dans les communes
saint-quentinoise le marathon pour la
recherche contre les maladies génétiques
rares se tient ce vendredi et samedi
cette information avant de développer
ces titres une personne placée en garde
à vue dans l'enquêté sur l'attentât de
magnanville un homme de 37 ans a été
interpellé hier aux mureaux par la sous
direction antiterroriste il s'agit d'un
proche de l'une de l'un des trois
individus déjà mises en examen dans
cette affaire
l homme est soupçonné d'avoir fourni une
complicité logistique aux intellectuels
aux tueurs du couple de policiers de
magnanville pour rappel jessica
schneider et jean baptiste salvin
avaient été assassinés au couteau devant
leur fils de trois ans
[Musique]
on prend tout de suite la direction de
ville pru des réfugiés tibétains sont
arrivés aujourd'hui dans la commune sur
décision de la préfecture cette mesure
fait suite à l'évacuation d'un campement
à achères en lisière de la forêt de
saint germain en laye ils séjourneront
sur place pendant un peu plus d'un mois
au complexe sportif alain mimoun les
détails avec piqué et demi d'euros leur
bus les a déposés aux alentours de 14
heures au gymnase alain mimoun de
villepreux ce mardi 3 décembre 91
réfugiés tibétains sont arrivés dans la
commune en provenance d'un campement de
fortune situé à achères un site évacué
par la préfecture un peu plus tôt dans
la matinée
maintenant je me sens mieux parce que
nous n'avions pas de maison la nuit
faisait vraiment très froid
on est très très très content on est
très satisfait on remercie vraiment
toutes les personnes qui ont contribué
bas à la victoire en fait parce que
c'est une victoire quand même pour nous
à leur arrivée les réfugiés ont été
accueillis avec un thé chaud et des
biscuits par une vingtaine d'habitants
de la commune venus bénévolement un élan
de solidarité qui a commencé via un
service de messagerie instantanée
dimanche dernier beaucoup de villes
provient ce sont mobilisés actuellement
on est à peu près 70 qui ont souhaité
donc venir en aide sur la logistique les
repas la convivialité éventuellement les
inviter chez nous de temps en temps
pendant la durée de leur séjour dans la
commune certaines activités associatives
de la ville ont dû être déplacés sur
d'autres sites
la première des choses c'est qu'en tant
que maire on a une crainte très égoïste
on se dit mais comment je vais faire
pour que la ville continue de
fonctionner il ya une très forte
collaboration de l'ensemble des
associations qui étaient impactés tout
simplement pour se mettre en phase qui
va aller ou pas ce que c'est vrai qu'on
perd quand même une salle majeurs dont
il fallait qu'on replace les
associations dans la ville les réfugiés
devrait rester jusqu'au 5 janvier dans
la commune ils seront deux nouveaux
déplacés dans une autre ville
après cette date à villepreux justement
une quatrième candidature connue pour
les élections municipales de 2020
l'ancienne adjointe sylvie ce vraiment
elle vient d'annoncer qu'elle se lançait
dans la course à la mairie elle conduit
la liste sans étiquette tous pour vip
rue composée d'anciennes élus de la
majorité de nouveaux visages une
décision motivée notamment suite à son
éviction de la majorité municipale cette
année face elle le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau a annoncé qu'il
briguerait un nouveau mandat jean
baptiste à mo'nique pour le modem et
valérie bain pour la liste agir pour
villepreux est d'ailleurs un toute
l'actualité des municipales 2020 a
retrouvé ce soir dans un nouveau numéro
du 7-8 politique présentée par wilfrid
richy à montigny le bretonneux une
vingtaine de travailleurs sans papiers
du bâtiment s'est mobilisée ce matin
réunis devant l'ancien bâtiment de
l'insee rue stephenson ils sont venus
dénoncer sur place leurs conditions de
travail déplorables sur ce chantier qui
a démarré un chantier de démolition
depuis un mois ces personnes sont
soutenus notamment par la cgt 78 qui
dénonce dans un communiqué une
exploitation brutal de ces travailleurs
sans papiers à qui l'on confie des
tâches les plus pénibles et les plus
dangereuses fin de citation le syndicat
demande l'intervention urgente de
l'urssaf et de l'inspection du travail
et mais aussi une régularisation de ces
travailleurs sans papiers est la ville
de mantes-la-jolie accueille la première
cuisine d'insertion du territoire elle
est installée dans le quartier du val
fourré une initiative et du conseil
départemental des yvelines et de
l'entreprise d'insertion un cerceau
soixante dix huit pour favoriser un
retour à l'emploi dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
mathilde de 2 min dans les cuisines
d'insertion de mantes-la-jolie quatre
personnes s'exerce au métier d'agent de
restauration en situation de handicap
demandeur d'emploi de longue durée ou
jeunes âgés de moins de 26 ans
ils participent tous au parcours
d'insertion professionnelle
elles sont recrutées en cdd d'insertion
ça peut aller jusqu'à 24 mois et on les
accompagne tout au long de leur parcours
sur la montée en compétences et en
qualification tout en travaillant en
parallèle sur la levée des freins
l'emploi qui peuvent être d'ordre
administratif mobilité forte logement en
cdd depuis août katia s'occupe
essentiellement de la légumerie un
endroit où elles lavent les fruits et
les légumes qui arrive du territoire un
changement radical pour elle qui
travaillait avant dans la restauration
rapide
je voulais connaître un peu autre chose
je voulais connaître notre production
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses pendant
déjà préparé un grande quantité entre
1500 et 2000 préparation sont distribués
dans le lycée franco allemand de buc et
le lycée international de saint germain
en laye à terme l'ambition et d'élargir
les capacités de production nous
considérons que bien nourrir les enfants
est une de nos missions donc vous avez
une unification tarifaire tous les
enfants du département désormais sont
traités à égalité sur les revenus des
parents et nous avons prévu dans cette
unification à travers la création de ces
midi des mesures aussi liées à
l'insertion des cuisines opérationnel et
pédagogiques pour former des personnes
en parcours d'insertion
à l'avenir ces midi et le département
souhaite créer de nouveaux postes en
insertion
les entreprises yvelinoise avait
rendez-vous aujourd'hui à versailles la
cci des yvelines la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie organisé la sixième
édition des smart bay sur place
rencontre entre pme start up grands
comptes et aussi avec les collectivités
territoriales tout un programme de
conférences de tables rondes pour
connaître les dernières innovations sur
la smart cities le thème de cet
événement est les interviews sont au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude la
smart city c'est la ville intelligente
la ville connectée c'est utiliser
des technologies justement pour aider le
citoyen à se sentir mieux dans sa ville
et justement à une ville plus durable
ce qui est important c'est que c'est du
travail et de collaboratif vous voyez
c'est des projets en travail
collaboratif et ça c'est très important
que l'on n'avait pu développer justement
cette synergie présenter un projet qui
est un projet
qui touchent le domaine du fluvial il
veut et temps d'acheminer la marchandise
dans paris par voie fluviale et de
sortir les déchets de paris aussi par
cette même voie fluviale donc iv et le
rapprochement par rapport à ce parti qui
fait quoi s'est déclenchée sur des
conditionnements des villes avec moins
de camions dans la ville moins de
pollution moins d'accidents moins de
nuisances sonores
il est situé au niveau de la route
nationale 10 à l'intersection de trois
communes coignières maurepas et là
derrière le carrefour de la malle me
donne va subir dans les prochaines
années un lifting à réaménagement de ce
secteur à qui doit s'achever en 2026
pour en parler bernard meyer bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le neuvième vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de la voirie de l'éclairage
public et de la sécurité une
concertation publique a été lancée
depuis le 18 novembre sur ce projet elle
s'achèvera le 20 décembre déjà en
préambule on peut parler d'un projet qui
était très attendue par par les élus par
les habitants oui alors attendu depuis
gelé dire quelques dizaines d'années
lorsque vous avez cette fameuse
départementale 13 qui a été coupé par la
nationale 10 donc c'était coupé à un axe
majeur s'est coupé les relations entre
les gens et avec tout le trafic et tous
les besoins de transport qui sont faits
notamment pour la gare de la verrière
était nécessaire de rétablir cette
liaison avec à carrefour adapté et qui
permet également de qui permettra si le
projet aboutit bien évidemment de
limiter et de supprimer les accidents
parce que vous le savez un certain
nombre d'accidents de gens qui ont
malgré tout tenté de traverser cette
nationale et vous le dites une dizaine
d'années qu'on en parle ça veut dire que
ça a été difficile de sortir ce projet
des cartons si je puis dire
le projet oui il faut dix ans vingt ans
même certains disent la réunion aux
précédentes qui a eu lieu le 21
septembre que interne au grand boucle
mais tu les as
faire ressortir par les intervenants on
va en parler que le projet était
attendue depuis plus de dix ans donc il
a été remis sur les rails depuis six ans
à peu près de 55 6 ans et supporter bien
évidemment par l'état par le département
et bien évidemment par l'agglomération
de saint quentin par le ralph's après un
projet chiffré à 20 millions d'euros
vous le dites il est devenu
incontournable il ya un enjeu
aujourd'hui de sécurité aussi de
fluidité de circulation sur sur ce
secteur non seulement de fluidité de
sécurité mais également de liaison entre
la commune de la verrière qui a besoin
d'être désenclaver pour pouvoir
giresse se tourner correctement vers
maurepas et toute la zone commerciale
qui à part dès qu'il ya par derrière
donc de permettre aux gens simplement de
pouvoir aller de pouvoir communiquer à
travers aussi bien à travers les
liaisons douces qui vont être réalisés
sur ce point à ce carrefour ce sera un
bon a priori n'anticipons pas le
résultat
et puis également des réseaux de bus
supplémentaires qui permettront aussi de
faciliter le passage d'un côté et l'eau
de l'autre de ceux de ce canal pourra
dire justement sur la nationale 10 on le
voit à travers ce projet mais aussi au
travers du projet d'enfouissement
attrape je crois que c'est la communauté
de coignières qui demande maintenant un
enfouissement la nationale 10 et
certains axes structurants et important
du territoire mais c'est un axe qui
coupent des ville en deux il ya
peut-être aussi une réflexion à avoir
sur l'insertion urbaine que doit avoir
cet axe de la nationale 10 tout à fait
c'est ce qui est ce qui se fait donc
grâce à la manne de dong a le punch
couleurs qui a été inaugurée
entre la verrière et mord pas un peu
plus à l'est du carrefour de la manne me
donne il y aura certainement à terme
c'est un projet national également le
pont de la ville yeux qui sera
nécessaire de revoir qui ont bien
évidemment au dessus de cette nationale
10 et plus à l'ouest qui a peut-être
aussi faciliter le passage de hauteur de
coignières parce que c'est un carrefour
à feux
un qui engorgent e7 nationale est facile
pas on va dire le la liaison routière
alors ce projet que prévoit-il en tout
cas dans les grandes lignes
rien est arrêté en corse et ça depuis
une concertation publique qui se déroule
actuellement
oui alors tout à fait c'est ça qui est
tout à fait intéressant parce que vous
avez cette concertation donc une
première concertation j'ai dit le 21
novembre la deuxième demain soir à
coignières et la troisième se sera à
maurepas le 12 décembre
ce sera également une concertation et
tout ce que tout se ces réunions sont
animées par un garant qu est ce qu un
garant c'est un homme qui est nommé
totalement indépendant par par l'état
pour être garant des bons échanges de la
bonne concertation qui engagent des
enjeux majeurs économique déménagement
du territoire environnementaux et de cul
te fasses de faire en sorte que toutes
les
les avis toutes les propositions soient
bien intégrés dans les réponses et dans
le futur document qui sera remis pour
valider ou invalider ce projet qui
souhaitons le aboutira donc on peut
participer à ces trois temps donc il y
en a une réunion qui est déjà passé de
la prochaine vous le dites c'est demain
à coignières ont je crois qu'on peut
aussi contribuer sur le site internet
il ya une adresse mail qu'elles ont pu
envoyer des questions ou des
questionnements sur sur ce sujet ce
exactement 2 il ya tout un moyen de tout
un ensemble de moyens mis à disposition
dans les mairies des par l'intermédiaire
de documents via internet
donc il ya les moyens d'entrer les
moyens de faire des suggestions des
propositions des remarques sont
extrêmement nombreux pour pour cette
concertation donc une co-construction
autour d'un projet qui est à déjà et
gérer
la mainmise des ingénieurs des
techniciens de l'état qui a un projet
fort intéressant mais qui ne peut être
que co construit comme tous les projets
qui se font aujourd'hui et s'est chiffré
à 20 millions d'euros 7 seront financés
par l'état 4 par l'agglomération 4 par
le département
c'est à dire qu'il manque 5 millions est
ce que vous êtes confiant ça peut être
un frein à ce projet ça pourrait être un
frein garde en le gardant l'espoir de
sommes là pour noël approche on va
garder l'espoir que le projet puisse
effectivement aboutir c'est un projet
vraiment majeurs alors le prochain
rendez vous le disais c'est demain à
coignières au salon saint-exupéry juste
pour le calendrier pour terminer quelles
sont les étapes les différentes étapes
qui vont animer ce projet une fois que
la concertation sera sera terminée les
questions ont reçu toutes leurs réponses
il ya ensuite une enquête d'utilité
publique qui aboutira à une déclaration
d'utilité publique
alors ça ça va nous emmener cette
déclaration du tpiy d'utilité publique
au début 2000 23 à peu près et pour un
démarrage des travaux
si effectivement l'ensemble du projet
est validé pour 2000 me 2023 et pour se
terminer à fin 2020 6 d'accord une mise
en service espérée d'ici fin 2020 6
espérons voilà en même temps que la fin
des travaux de la nationale 10 les
travaux qui ont commencé
donc il y aura un bel axe qui sera à
disposition et des riverains et des
personnes qui transitent un point
important le la circulation sera limitée
à 70 km heure
merci pour ces précisions et bernard
meyer 9e vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines et je rappelle que cette
concertation publique est ouverte
jusqu'au 20 décembre
autre grand dossier à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du côté de
voisins-le-bretonneux une nouvelle
réunion publique se tenait ce lundi
concernant le projet de la remise en
écoquartier qui est en discussion depuis
2015 lévis ynwa présents hier ont
découvert les plants ainsi que les
promoteurs qui assureront les travaux
les précisions de mathilde et demi
c'est ici que va se construire 500
logements en écoquartier à voisins le
bretonneux pour cette réunion publique
le projet a été présenté et comportera
une éco crèche une maison de quartier
des nouveaux commerces mais aussi des
jardins partagés
ces normes
qu'ils s'inquiètent de comment le
quartier va fonctionner avec une idée se
soit pas une verrue mais que ce soit
bien quelque chose qui leur profite à
eux aussi je pense qu'ils ont pu voir
turin par taux très généreux où ils ont
ils pourraient profiter puisque
aujourd'hui la remise
ça reste une friche ou pas grand monde
ne peut aller et puis bien sûr il faut
qu'on réponde à toutes les questions
d'usagé en particulier la place de la
voiture et de la circulation dense carte
habitants du quartier de la remise
sandra a créé le collectif pour la
remise à cause de ses inquiétudes sur
l'aboutissement du projet de
l'aménagement des quartiers pour elle
plus de réponses ont été apportées à
cette réunion aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
réponse en termes de transport sur des
bus de lignes de bus
on n'a pas de réponse sur la sécurité
des piétons comme on en crée ton
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont prendre un
risque à chaque fois qu'on veut
traverser la route aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de réponse
il ya eu des tests ont été faits qu'il
ya eu quasiment un mort et aujourd'hui
on n'a pas des pansements q donc
agissons pour vraiment sécurisé et
fluidifier la circulation et faire en
sorte effectivement ça soit un
écoquartier qui soit bon à vivre malgré
certaines craintes de la part des
habitants
les architectes associés au projet
espèrent que l'éco quartier voit le jour
dans moins de quatre ans on va encore
écouté les doléances on va les intégrer
dans le projet on va amender les parties
que l'on peut amender on va tenir bon
sur ses locaux tenir bon donc là en ce
moment nous sommes en train en tant
qu'ordonnateur avec les autres
architectes de dessiner de façon précise
l'ensemble des différents lots qui vont
comporter les logements depuis 2015 le
projet divise mais les premiers travaux
pour le club de bicross ont déjà
commencé et les premiers logements
pourraient être livrés en fin d'année
[Musique]
c'est le marathon pour récolter des dons
en faveur de la recherche contre les
maladies génétiques rares le 33e
téléthon c'est ce week-end plus
précisément à vendredi et samedi
prochain même si dans certaines communes
on continuera le téléthon aussi le
dimanche à saint quentin en yvelines
encore une fois cette année les
associations sont grandement mobilisés
pour cet événement solidaire bonsoir
daniel tamam bon ça vous êtes le
président d'objectif téléthon maniwaki
organisons que le téléthon dans la
commune de magny les hameaux
magny les hameaux moins de 10000
habitants il n'empêche que chaque année
les une grande mobilisation pour cet
événement oui absolument
neuf mille trois cents habitants
exactement une grande mobilisation parce
que c'est un moment que nous souhaitons
festif et puis les mails et m'a dit quoi
leurs familles leurs amis se sentent
absolument concernés pourquoi il faut se
mobiliser pour ce téléthon pourquoi
c'est un événement qui vous tient à
coeur
chaque année pourquoi il nous tient à
coeur déjà ne sommes pas directement
concerné nous le faisons nous avons la
santé nous le faisons pour ceux qui ont
un peu plus besoin que nous il ya des
avancées significatives
il ya besoin d'argent
7 cette opération téléthon c'est une
récolte c'est le moment idéal pour faire
une récolte qui assure mme annie
représente 2 euros 88 par habitant c'est
un très très beau chiffre il faut
absolument le faire parce que c'est 3,4
millions de français potentiellement
concernés nos enfants voilà pourquoi les
pourquoi nous nous battons plus de 20000
euros récoltés à magny les hameaux
l'année dernière en séance
un peu plus de 19000 séance et le samedi
soir et puis la télématique c'est
l'engagement fait par téléphone ou
internet nous a amené un peu plus de
25000 euros
c'est un très très beau chiffre
l'objectif cette année c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est déjà de remplir le
gymnase c'est faire venir les gens qui
sentent un peu un peu concerné par le
sujet et puis aussi on fait un chiffre
aussi bon c'était vraiment content on se
bat pour en tous les cas c'est aussi un
objectif humain c'est de rassembler les
manies quoi mais aussi les autres
habitants des tissus les collines
environnantes autour c'est tellement
bien sûr digestif
ça va durer 24 heures de vendredi 19h
samedi 19h l'année dernière il y avait
un thème spécifique c'était la chine est
ce que vous avez prévenu en mai intel
chacun de s'imprégner un petit peu de se
mettre dans l'ambiance s'attendait
effectivement il ya un thème qui est
gourmandise et bonbonnière alors
pourquoi pas c'est original
on va décorer claude gymnase dans 10
pays dit m
et qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir du
programme cette année alors déjà un
moment fort on vous l'avait dit qui va
démarrer vendredi à 19 heures qui se
terminera 24 25 heures plus tard déjà ça
c'est le moment fort et pendant tout ce
temps là il y aura des spectacles des
démonstrations sportives des des
concerts des jeux
des spectacles à l'extérieur également
tout ça se passe sur un endroit original
chantal mauduit royaume bourven raté un
rouleau de bourg et commence à se
préparer nous reste une hutte un tel
événement est ce que chaque année il
faut remobiliser les bénévoles alors on
voit que dans d'autres associations
c'est difficile de mobiliser les
bénévoles est ce que là pour cet
événement mais il ya des difficultés
aussi manier m o c est une grande
famille alors c'est pas très compliqué
en fait le moment opportun c'est le
forum des associations c'est le moment
où on peut commencer à tisser toutes les
toutes les relations aient pu bâtir
bâtir ce programme qui est proposé en
fait à l'issue du forum des associations
on a trois quarts du des spectacles qui
seront pleins trois quarts de la séance
nous soit quoi pour ce 33e téléthon de
la fréquentation et on retrouve toutes
les informations sur le site de la ville
notamment un de magny les hameaux merci
daniel tamam d'être passé en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le président
d'objectif téléthon manico un téléthon à
magny les hameaux 1 du vendredi 19
heures au samedi 19 heures dans la
commune plusieurs communes d'ailleurs un
de saint quentin en yvelines se
mobilisent à l'occasion de cet événement
le programme deuxième édition du
téléthon à coignières avec animation le
samedi au gymnase soirée country rock le
samedi soirée concert gospel le dimanche
à villepreux l événement est bien
maintenue au complexe alain mimoun et ce
avec l'accueil des réfugiés tibétains
certaines activités pourrait tout de
même un se déroulait à l'école le clou
crozatier le téléthon est très sportive
du côté de montigny le bretonneux
challenge atelier lancers-francs marche
nocturne 30 heures à vivre au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin enfin à
voisins le bretonneux les 30 heures
seront axés autour d'un fil rouge un
voyage dans le temps l'association les
belles villes chinoises partage sa
passion pour les véhicules de collection
c'était en août dernier le département
des yvelines a accueilli le plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre et quatre mois après la tenue
de l'édition 2019 de l'est qui rendent
au l'organisation a souhaité faire le
bilan les précisions d'aurélie rosé de
gwenaëlle saintilan 808 et qui rendent
ans issus de neuf nationalités se sont
retrouvés du 1er au 4 août dernier au
haras des bréviaires pour la 52e édition
de l'est qui rendent au
quatre mois après l'heure est au bilan
au delà même de ses trois jours au haras
des bréviaires
les cavaliers leurs familles ont
sillonné des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de territoires c'est le cas
dans les forêts domaniales mais
également à travers les plaines
ça a permis d'animer les yvelines en
tout cas ce sud yvelines à cette période
de l'année
un succès populaire pour ce plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre
douze mille personnes ont assisté le 3
août au défilé dans les rues de
rambouillet le point d'orgue de la
manifestation un bilan positif également
au niveau économique
cent soixante mille euros ont été
injectés dans le territoire sud evelyne
l événement a notamment dopé le tourisme
très belle vitrine pour le département
pour prêt pour protéger et puis pour
promouvoir cette ruralité et ce tourisme
local et surtout le tourisme équestre
il ya déjà une trentaine de gîtes qui
ont été inscrits par la société ic i
move dans des gîtes qui permettent
d'accueillir des personnes mais aussi
des chevaux ce qu'ils vont développer le
tourisme local sur le sud yvelines
premier département équestre de france
par son nombre de licenciés et les
yvelines compte bien profiter du
dynamisme créés par l'événement pour les
jeux olympiques en 2024
le haras des bréviaires pourrait être un
lieu de référence il nous quittait il y
a deux ans johnny hallyday s'est éteint
le 5 décembre 2010 est à 74 ans une
messe hommage à l'idole des jeunes se
déroule ce samedi à 18h30 c'est en
l'église saint-pierre du lac à montigny
le bretonneux organisé par un habitant
grand fan du chanteur avec l'accord de
la commune et de la paroisse des bikers
devraient faire le déplacement pour cet
office ou des intentions de prières
seront est dédiée à l'artiste disparu
son titre au mari sera joué également à
l'orgue en fin de messe
les propos sont recueillis par mathilde
et demi j'ai toujours été fan de johnny
à fond dedans à fond dedans dès qu'il
faut
j'ai quand j'allais au parc des postes
il y avait cinq concerts jaleo s'imposer
au stade de france avec quatre concerts
jallow quatre concerts des liquidités
sur paris puis qu'il y avait des aux
aînés tout à l'olympia où depuis voilà
et puis moi j'ai commencé à 10 heures
quand il était tout jeune j'allais au
golf drouot en face du café de
l'angleterre ce soir sur tv 60,18 vous
avez rendez vous avec le 7-8 culture
avec aux manettes
aurélie ronge bonsoir de la rédaction de
tv 78 quel est le programme de cette
émission je crois qu'il y aura du rock
notamment exactement puisque on va
revenir sur la soirée les studios ont du
coeur c'était samedi dernier à la
batterie de guyancourt alors le concept
plusieurs concerts pour la bonne cause
avec en tête d'affiché les rocker johnny
montreuil et didier wampas autre style
musical puisque on parlera du groupe
dell grèce le trio était en concert au
prisme à elancourt ils étaient venus
faire découvrir son album mojo dit ça
veut dire mort aujourd'hui en créole à
vous le verrez un album engagé aux
accents de blues caribéens et puis on
parlera de danse également avec le coup
de coeur du directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lionel masse
et à il nous parlera de ce qui se
passera le week-end du 13 décembre
la chorégraphe joseph beuys viendra
présenter son spectacle d'est en ouest
et puis dans ce numéro il y aura
également
de la littérature ou encore on parlera
de festival de cannes le 7 une culture
ce soir sur tv 78 merci aux riches
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité rendez vous demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]